lisa is with us in New York hi Lisa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
I'm a question um I am going to be 42 on
Sunday and I have about 52,000 and
savings 18 of which is for annum 18,000
of which is for an emergency fund I'm
debt free my annual income is about
57,000 a year I live in New York City so
it sounds like a lot but I have a
roommate and so it's difficult here's my
question I'm being told I have about
four hundred dollars a month left over
that I've been putting toward a down
payment on an apartment and I'm being
told now to sort of abandon that goal
and start saving for retirement because
at the moment I only have about 20,000
and a retirement account and I'm behind
I'm not sure what direction to go I feel
like I'm about 25,000 or so away from a
down payment for a place in New York
City but I could move someplace for a
cheaper you know for a cheaper housing
at some point in which case what I have
would would do the trick for 20% down I
just want to do an advice on that in
terms of do I abandoned everything and
start saving for retirement now or do I
keep heading toward my down payment goal
first when you say New York City do you
mean Manhattan um Queens
it'll be Queens and out of the question
okay yeah I was thinking on 57 grand
know that should happen
yeah that's your income right yes sir
yeah so so basically you're telling you
got about 35,000 saved now about 34,000
if you use 18 as your emergency fund
number right correct
and that's not enough to do a down
payment today uh no but I mean our
minimum is about a few hundred thousand
dollar plays yeah you can really just
you wouldn't be putting 20% down but you
could get into something I could but I
always thought 20% down was it was that
or don't do it kind of thing not with me
but it is on a first home it's wise and
the reason is is you avoid the PMI the
private mortgage insurance and because
and that cost you about you know about
seventy-five bucks a month
per hundred thousand borrowed so if
you're doing $200,000 do it 150 bucks a
month eighteen hundred dollars a year
that you're just is gone so it's like
paying another another you know what a
quarter of a point or half a point
interest rates what it amounts to we're
not having a good strong a big enough
down payment so you know if you want to
go ahead and buy and do a 15-year fixed
and have your payment no more than 1/4
of your take-home pay including the PMI
and then drop the PMI off later that's
fine if you want to save up for a while
longer that's fine
another 25,000 at the rate of $400 a
month which is $5,000 a year is going to
take you five more years it's wrong
right
it's longer than I want I'd like to see
you know if you want to save for another
two or three years and really go crazy
and save even more than what you're
saving now per month and do it for two
or three more years that's fine and then
say that's what I'm going to start my
retirement
so I'm guessing whoever is telling you
this is probably the person selling you
retirement stuff no big friend okay a
couple of different friends just mean
well and you know I want you to get
started on retirement I want you to get
started on a house I like both ideas and
if you can get to the house soon enough
to not mess up your retirement you're
fine and soon enough in my minds two or
three more years okay so I'm not super
late especially given I'll be filling
about seven eight hundred dollars a
month out it once I start doing it you
ought to be doing more than that you'll
be saving 15% of your household income
under which I to my brother right yeah
of your gross into retirement into the
raw yeah all right yeah if you do if you
do that from age 45 to age 65 you'll
retire with dignity and a paid for house
because you'll be on a 15-year fixed on
the house and the house will be paid for
gosh yeah I got it we have a 20 year
game plan starting from age 45 you're 42
right now that I can do all that right
yep yep and so you'll be fine if you do
that
the trick is to not just lollygag along
and not have a plan for both I
understand and I think that's probably
where your friends are kind of messed up
because they're just looking at one of
these things because you know if you
don't save up and buy for a house and
you went with airplane you say okay I'm
gonna pile everything into retirement
starting right now I'm never going to
buy a house yeah what's that all
basically it like that stinks let me
wrap my heart
what's a dumb plan to yeah I mean I'm
buying a house is a smart plan as part
of your overall plan so to say never buy
a house and save for retirement because
you're 42 what's dumb my grades oh wait
you know so your friends are dumb is
what I'm saying there I guess I should
rephrase that their advice was done in
that well yeah hey thanks for the call